[Music]
the disaster is here after the writer
strike actors in the United States are
now also taken to the streets what this
means for our favorite movies and series
you can find out now in the Koch news
updates on James gun's new Superman
movie don't seem to cease first the
director revealed more information about
the story and then some new Heroes and
their actors who will play a part in
Superman Legacy were announced just
recently the principal cast of Clark Ken
and Lois Lane was revealed which will be
played by David cornat and Rachel
Brosnahan now three more names join them
Isabella mer will play shayera hole more
commonly known as Hawk girl she fights
on behalf of the good guys but has a
fiery temperament and prefers to throw
herself into battle with swords Spears
and Masons likewise Michael halt aka Mr
terrific will join the cast played by
Eddie gy the character is mainly an
ingenious inventor with all kinds of
technical gadgets and later becomes part
of the justice league in the comics also
new to the cast Anthony carrian known
from the series Barry he is to play the
role of Rex Mason better known as
metamorpho the superhero with the
ability to change his shape the final
addition to the cast is the popular cult
actor Nathan fillian he will portray a
Green Lantern and also take on this role
in the planned Lantern Series in
addition to the news about the Superman
legacy cast director and screenwriter
James gun commented on the story of the
film according to him it is not an
origin story so it will not retold how
Superman came to Earth instead the movie
focuses on the young years of Clark Kent
and his early days at the Daily Planet
filming on Superman Legacy is expected
to kick off in early 2024 with a
theatrical release slated for July 11th
2025 fans of Alita battle Angel listen
up apparently we can expect several
sequels of the action movie James camon
revealed this detail to Forbes Magazine
in a very extraordinary setting namely
during the sale of his Mansion producer
John landow already commented on Alita 2
a while ago they would love to do it
there were already talks with director
Robert Rodriguez but nothing was set in
stone yet and then there's James Cameron
the third big name behind the project
he's currently planning to sell his
Coastal Ranch in California for $33
Million by the way and in an interview
with Forbes he describes at length the
rooms in which he wrote avatar for
example but almost casually he tells us
that he is now working in Wellington and
Los Angeles on the next Avatar SE seals
and in Austin on the new Alita battle
Angel movies that's right movies plural
so not only does Cameron confirm that
the sequel is definitely in the works
but we can probably also look forward to
aita battle Angel re the franchise is
based on the popular mea series battle
Angel Alita which has produced numerous
volumes in 2019 the story was filmed For
the First Time starring Rosa Salazar and
Christopher Waltz the movie convinced
both critics and movie goers and since
then many have been eagerly waiting for
the story to be continued well there is
plenty of material so it's not
surprising that we can expect not only
one more movie but also a lead of three
or more we will keep you up to date on
further
news the next setback for Hollywood with
the writer strike already affecting the
movie business the next catastrophe is
just around the corner as of Thursday
morning it's clear that the tough
negotiations between the studios and the
actor Union sag Afra have failed this
means that it as good as certain that
new numerous us actors will also go on
strike for the movie and series industry
the two strikes are probably the biggest
challenge of the 21st century so far
since the beginning of May the often
neglected writers in Hollywood have been
on strike for better wages and working
conditions so far this is already
resulted in a halt to production on
Stranger Things Blade the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power and many other
projects and almost all well-known late
night talk shows have been put on hold
as well current reports show just how
hard the battle is being fought the
iance of Motion Pictures and television
producers amtp in particular is doing a
poor job some insiders report that
further negotiations are being
deliberately delayed until the fall so
that the authors are financially
devastated and would become homeless in
which they would have to agree to less
favorable conditions there is even talk
of an alleged cruel but necessary
negotiations between the union and
producers on a new Collective Agreement
have recently stalled the actors are
also demanding better payment and
working conditions after all the trend
towards fewer episodes lower budgets and
exploitation by streaming providers
caused significant losses for the actors
this is currently also causing celebrity
Advocates Ben Stiller Pedro Pascal
Jennifer Lawrence Bob Odenkirk and
others to take to the streets even
though they probably have less trouble
making ends meet however they are vocal
in their solidarity with their
colleagues one thing is certain the
strikes are a severe setback for
numerous Productions and not just for
purely us ones many International
Productions are dependent on Hollywood
par participation some projects have
already been put on hold due to the
upcoming actor strike including
Gladiator 2 Mortal Kombat 2 the future
Alien series and many more in total the
actor's Union has nearly 160,000 members
which means that more or less all
current Productions are affected whether
in the United States or elsewhere fans
are now rightfully concerned about their
long awaited films and series which have
to be postponed for an indefinite period
of time we'll keep you posted as soon as
there's more news from the heated front
between actors and writers on one side
and producers and streaming providers on
the
other this week there was a downright
mass of trailers for many upcoming
projects from DC to Star Wars and more
there's a little something for everyone
much attention has been drawn to the
second trailer for the DC movie Blue
Beetle the video shows some action and
more information about the plot that
viewers can expect in the film The
opinions on the net are mixed some
people predict the next DC flop like
Shazam 2 While others expect a fun
spectacle Blue Beetle tells the story
story of teenager Jamie Reyes who
inherits the power of the so-called Blue
Beetle this is an alien Scarab that
gives him superhuman Powers the movie
will be released on August 18th 2023 the
second trailer for the upcoming Star
Wars series Ahsoka has been released the
series follows Jedi Knight Ahsoka Tano
former Padawan of none other than Anakin
Skywalker the trailer shows a lot of New
Impressions and is causing a veritable
Buzz among viewers this is due to the
numerous elements from clone wars and
the like that are now being incorporated
into to the liveaction series above all
the appearance of thrawn ahsoka's Archen
enemy you might be pleased about the
release of the first trailer for Wonka
the movie by the makers of Paddington
tells the story of the world famous
chocolate manufacturer Willie Wonka and
provides more insight into how he
actually built up his Empire on December
15th dunar shalomay will be seen in his
new role on the big screen the first
trailer for the movie Napoleon came out
this week in the historical Drama by
Ridley Scott Wen Phoenix takes on the
role of the famous French General and
dictator the movie promises to be an
original and personal look at Napoleon's
rise to become emperor and his often
volatile relationship with his wife
Josephine if you're interested in
history and would like to see Joker star
Wen Phoenix back in Action you should
not miss the theatrical release on
November 22nd
2023 that was this week's news what are
your thoughts on this massive double
strike are we in for another period of
hard times in terms of great films and
series after the movie industry has just
survived the aftermath of the pandemic
we look forward to your opinion in the
[Music]
comments